let's go to the phones at 617-830-4750
let's see if it's a good phone's day
or a bad phone's day 617-830-4750
starting with our caller from the 516
area code who's calling today from 516.
hey is that me yeah who's this hey i'm
nick from
new york nick from new york what's going
on my friend
so i would like to know what is the plan
to stop trump from suppressing the vote
in november
i wish i knew i mean listen
um so there's a couple different things
going on here
and it's like you've got the
paramilitaries in portland and soon
likely to be other
cities possibly they will remain to
intimidate into november
you've got trump trying to prevent vote
by mail which is really just expanding
absentee ballots
you've got you know all of the players
that want to interfere in the election
still plan to you know russia possibly
china etc
i think the plan has to be we overwhelm
the vote by so much that the
interference doesn't matter i mean i
hate to say it but i don't know what the
plan is nick
that's a great idea though i mean i mean
i hope
it works i hope that we do get this
president out of office because he's so
incompetent
yeah are you what state uh so do you
vote in new york
i'm actually too young to vote i'm 17.
oh my god
yeah that's okay unfortunately
if you could vote though you would not
vote for trump it sounds like
i would totally vote for biden got it
okay and so are you um
are you between high school and college
right now are you about to be a senior
i'm about to be a senior and what's are
you going back for in person or is it
virtual classes i have no idea
but you just you still don't even know
yeah i don't know yet
what would you prefer well i would
i mean i'm okay with either one
obviously i'd rather go in person
you would say and you'd what you'd wear
a mask you'd be okay with it
yeah yeah you do your parents have
strong feelings one way or the other
uh what what'd you say do your parents
have a strong feeling about whether they
want you
physically in school i don't know i
would have to ask them
oh all right nick very good glad you're
paying attention to the voter
suppression it's going to be a big deal
i appreciate the call
thank you so much for taking it all
right take care nick from new york got
right to the question i love it